im nordrhein-westfälischen Harsewinkel
hat die Stadt vor drei Jahren sechs neue
Photovoltaikanlagen auf verschiedene
öffentliche Gebäude gesetzt Kosten
stolze 217.000 Euro doch seitdem liegen
sie nutzlos auf den Dächern herum sind
nicht ans Stromnetz angeschlossen der
Grund die Stadt hat es nicht geschafft
die Anlagen zertifizieren zu lassen sich
in das unfassbar dass diese PV-Anlage
immer noch nicht angeschlossen ist und
die so viel Geld kostet wenn man es
nicht an Stromnetz anschließt geht
natürlich sehr viel Geld verloren und
dann hätte man auch die Photovoltaik bzw
PV-Anlage nicht aus Dach installieren
müssen
2017 beschließt die Stadt die
zusätzlichen Photovoltaikanlagen zu
kaufen doch ab 2019 brauchen auch solche
kleinere Anlagen ein spezielles
Zertifikat mit der die Einhaltung
technischer Standards nachgewiesen wird
für die Solarmodule in Harsewinkel
eigentlich kein Problem denn die Anlagen
werden 2020 montiert und da gilt noch
eine Übergangsfrist doch diese Frist
lässt die Stadt verstreichen also ich
halte das für hane Büchen in der freien
Wirtschaft dürfte sowas nicht passieren
also da wäre derjenige der
verantwortlich ist
müsste da eigentlich um seinen
Arbeitsplatz Wangen bis heute sind die
Anlagen weder zertifiziert noch
angeschlossen jahrelang hat die Stadt
keine Firma gefunden die die notwendigen
Papiere ausstellt der Schaden für die
nicht produzierten Strom beträgt
mittlerweile mehr als 80.000 € im
Rathaus weist man die Schuld von sich
ich bin keine Technikerin und ich war
eben auch noch bisher noch nicht in
dieses Verfahren involviert aber selbst
wenn ich involviert gewesen wäre hätte
ich nicht aufs Dach steigen können um
sie mal eben anzuschließen um es ganz
deutlich zu sagen und im Wesentlichen
sind es diese bürokratischen
Herausforderungen die uns jetzt diese
letzten zwei ein Vierteljahre
beschäftigt haben doch dafür haben viele
Bürger in Harsewinkel wenig Verständnis
auch wenn es an einer komplizierten
Zertifizierung liegt bin ich der Meinung
eine Behörde wie die Stadt Harsewinkel
sollte das irgendwie eine Wege geleitet
bekommen weil jeder Privatmann muss das
ja auch schaffen weggeschmissenes Geld
das jetzt quasi gebaut wurden und jetzt
einfach nur rumliegen und das schon
mehrere Jahre und eine Firma die das
notwendige Zertifikat ausstellen könnte
hat die Stadt nun endlich gefunden
trotzdem wird es wohl noch Monate dauern
bis die Anlagen endlich ans Netz gehen